[Music]
I have a poem in here that is about uh
my dog Jesse this is not an earth
shattering poem it's just about my dog
Jesse who uh we had to put down
um Jesse my dog
I was driving back from a music recital
this evening and found myself cruising
down a street I used to Frid 30 years
ago but haven't driven down
since so many of the places I used to go
to a gone a favorite Italian restaurant
now a fitness center a bookstore now an
antique store a cafe where I read most
of 100 Years of Solitude now an ice
cream parlor
it isn't as if I was planning to go to
any of those places but it makes me sad
to know they're gone it doesn't really
matter I'm 72 years
old a lot is
gone it's all going to go
eventually by the cafe a boy was walking
his dog along the
sidewalk one day the boy will be gone
along with his
dog my dog's gone
Jesse used to lie by my feet as I sat at
the computer trying to write a poem
she's gone now no more
Jesse after I'd written the poem i' take
Jesse out for her midnight walk
sometimes would pass a house and the
people inside might still be up sitting
at the table talking and drinking but
mostly the streets were quiet and she
and I would enjoy the night air the way
the leaves rustled when a wind came up
from the ocean
maybe a poem would be buried in
someone's front yard and Jesse would dig
it up and bring it to me like a bone
she'd just
found that poem about the man in charge
of watering Jesse dug that one up she
just dug it up and brought it to me what
you got there girl she dropped it on the
sidewalk then Trott it off looking for
more poems more
bones no more bones now and few poems to
be dug up except this one which is torn
at the edges and I've stopped caring
about the line breaks or the metaphors
or even the kind of things a poet is
supposed to do when writing a poem
making everything ship
shape no more bones no more ship shape
I'm not even sure you are reading this
poem right now maybe no one is reading
it like I said earlier it doesn't matter
you know I write the poems
anyway Jesse will come back some night
take my poems on our walk and bury them
in someone's front yard and all I'll
have to do in my remaining years is walk
my weary bones down the sidewalk and dig
them up dig up those poems that Jesse
buried my good girl
dog taking such good care of me then end
now Jesse won't be with me but I'll
thank her give her a good rub on the
back then I'll let her
go so that's about my dog Jess that's
beautiful so it's not so much Rhythm as
the voice you
know sometime there are rhythmic things
you can do and that's part of your
Technique so it depends if I'm doing to
be read and sung you know the repetition
then I would do that you know it's also
about loss and change you know you you
talked about walking down the street and
this restaurant isn't here anymore and
this bookstore has changed most it's
about I'm 70 I wrote that when I was 72
I'm 78 now so I wrote that six years ago
it's about
thinking you know as I said my dad died
when he was 54 and I I wasn't I always
thought I would live longer than he did
so you know when I wrote the poem I was
and you know I'm feel
feeling older your bones your body you
don't you know I can't dunk
anymore you know I can't throw a
football 70 yards uh and so you also
think of what you can't do as an artist
that you're getting older
and uh things are going to be gone
you're going to lose things friends will
die and loved ones will leave and I was
just thinking about that and feeling all
that uh and that Jesse was gone but um I
thought of how she would bury my palms
and then dig them up which is a metaphor
of course
um and that eventually I'd pet her and
let her go that at some point the poems
don't come anymore and the Muse that
brings you the poems whether it's your
dog or the Muse or whatever that will
end too and you have to let it go you
have to give him a pet and Let It
Go whether it's a poem or a lover a
loved one friend whatever in the history
of our
family uh when we think of defining
moments there's one moment that stands
above all the others and it was the
moment when uh our son Peter as a five
and a half yearold little boy was
diagnosed with a brain tumor
and our pediatrician put the MRI films
in our hands and said you need to drive
to UCLA Medical Center a brain surgeon
will be waiting for you and uh he'll
explain
everything and so Kathy and I got in the
car and oh and the doctor said and don't
stop anywhere on the way so we put our
son in the car drove to the ER and as we
turned into the entrance to the ER we
looked at each other and I think Kathy
was the one who said In This Moment Like
Our Lives are changing
forever and that was true we now in in
our family talk about the moment Before
Peter got sick and we talk about the
moment after Peter's brain
tumor my daughter's life
experience was different from that
moment on uh her best friend um and
brother suddenly was out of her life and
in the hospital and she wasn't seeing
him and when she did finally see him
after surgery he was
changed uh the tumor was gone but he
didn't speak didn't
walk uh he looked to her like a
monster and
for Peter that was a defining moment it
was a moment that crippled him that made
him and Peter many years later is
alive but as a result of the surgery
radiation which isn't good for little
boys brains and
chemotherapy he's kind of a real life
Forest Gump U pure of
heart and um and he knows what love is
and he
struggles um
intellectually so that was a moment of
wounding for
him it was the beginning of the death of
the dreams that we had for him we had to
find new dreams to replace the ones that
died and it took a long time though we
we were the ones who were dragged
Kicking and Screaming
to
recognizing the dreams that were not
going to happen now for
him even as we approached his 16th
birthday
and people his age were going to get
driver's
licenses U none of us wants to live in a
world where Peter Riley has a driver's
license because he just cannot process
all of the information fast enough and
he would get it right 95% of the time
but that's not that's not enough on the
streets of
LA and so I had to eventually say to him
Peter you're not going to get a driver's
license and so he's found a new dream he
heard about the Google car and so he's
all about a self-driving car as soon as
he can get one he wants a car that's
going to take him wherever it can take
him
we had to absorb a lot of of
losses but a day came
when um Peter had struggled along in
school got to high
school and in California there's a test
you have to pass in order to get a
diploma uh called the California high
school exit exam it's a standardized
test so no matter how much people at the
school loved him and helped him there
was no way he was going to get a diploma
if he didn't pass this
test and I remember the day that the
results came in the mail and uh I just
heard Kathy screaming in the other part
of the house she'd opened the envelope
and he had passed by like a
whisker and uh and so we got to go to
his high school graduation
and uh you know I've been in high school
and I know how it works people applaud
based on how popular you are uh when
your name is called and so my family had
all come to his graduation and I was
telling everybody you've got to like
cheer your brains out because we have to
be as loud as
possible um and Kathy was just saying oh
I just I don't care about that I just
hope he doesn't fall off the stage and
they called his name
and the entire senior class came to
their feet applauding because they all
recognized what he had overcome in order
to earn that diploma how old was your
dad when he found out he had terminal
cancer 48 I think he was 48 if memory
serves
um yeah I think he was around
48 and uh he got diagnosed with renal
cell carcinoma which is a kid kidney
cancer he removed a softball siiz tumor
off of his kidney um he was a vegetarian
didn't drink didn't smoke you know had a
pretty healthy lifestyle but it just
gotten out of a really bad multi-year
lawsuit uh that caused a lot of stress
which probably probably helped out a lot
I'm sure um but yeah it was at the time
they had given him eight months and so
we pushed up our wedding and everything
he ended up lasting eight years he was a
fighter for sure he definitely fought uh
tooth and nail and so ended up lasting
about eight years on it which was great
and where were you when you found out
it's funny I actually remember exactly
where I was I was working at the video
super store in Orlando Florida and he
called while I was on a shift and I
remember going out and sitting in the
car on my lunch break I think and he
told me about it I remember yeah I
remember very vividly um and it was just
kind of like oh oh okay you know this
this big hit
of of what uh you know kind of kind of
re how do you reevaluate your Lifestyles
and your life at that point CU you're
kind of like oh wow okay and makes you
really realize really quickly how sacred
life is for sure but I remember sitting
in my 88 Suburban in that parking lot
when he called and told us and it was
like
oh okay and then trying to figure out
what to do from
there and when you walked by back into
the store did the store look
different in a way cuz your perspective
now everything was turned upside
down I don't know if necessarily my
perspective was completely turned upside
down it was more so
of okay okay like what do we do next
what's the next step I'm definitely a
very structured kind of person so it's
like all right if I have to accomplish
something what do I have to do to get
there like okay what's next we do
surgery next okay we do the surgery
remove the tumor okay then what's after
that then we start chemotherapy okay so
I like what's the plan to get to our
goal of remission so I think my mind was
kind of more thinking that way
than thinking about
oh I'm going to go cry for an hour and a
half you know and be sad I think it was
more so about okay here we are what do
we have to do to accomplish our goal to
make to make this work to make this
better
um
which of course you only have so much
say in because it's uh it's a disease
but then they started the processes
and he stuck around for another eight
years it was crazy it was cool how did
that day impact his life and how did
that day impact yours he definitely made
a lot of choices and changes after that
he moved back to his home state
Louisiana he got close to family over
there he ended up meeting um a woman
Beth who they started a relationship and
she had a big farm and he started a farm
which he never had a farm before we
bought him goats for Christmas I
remember or sheep sheep sheep and goats
that was fun and started this
farm he was a lawyer and a judge for uh
years and so he kind of took to this
retirement he would have to go to
Houston to do chemotherapy and through
the MD Anderson Center and um then after
a few of those years he started
traveling you know trying to travel to
places that he hadn't been to
he tried to kind of live live the best
he could he got remarried during that to
Beth and you know lived as much as he
could possibly
do but it was interesting because at the
end I have uh two of my sisters and I
went and stayed with them two weeks
apart so we each had two weeks with them
and I had the last two weeks and I was
leaving because our short 222 was
playing at grumman's Chinese Theater
here in Hollywood which was the first
time i' had ever had a movie play in
Hollywood let alone at the Chinese
Theater it was a huge huge de deal and I
was there with him for 2 weeks and then
I took a flight to Hollywood met my wife
she flew out from Florida we went to
this whole red carpet had this whole
incredible experience got meetings from
Studios and all this different stuff I
put her back on a flight the next day
because I had set up a few days worth of
meetings while I was there and as soon
as she got on the flight and left I
remember going back and I was just
hanging out just looking at the
Hollywood Sign soaking everything in and
then I get a call saying he's not going
to last the next day
so it was really crazy experience it was
like the highest and lowest point I
think I'd ever experienced in the same
time frame and so I was like well okay
and so I went and booked a flight you
know flew back to the small town
Louisiana that he was in canceled all my
meetings canceled everything and um and
yeah he passed away the next day and so
it was a crazy Whirlwind for sure
um and with what's even crazier is uh 3
months after that my step brother ended
up getting killed by an accidental
shooting and three months after that my
wife's mother died of cancer so it was a
very crazy year um and also our son was
born right after she passed away a few
months after she passed he was born but
it really you know going back to the
whole horror element it really lit a
fire to where it's like all right you
know your life is not guaranteed
tomorrow's not guaranteed like you got
to get going you got to make sure that
everything you're doing is impacting the
way that you want it to go and to help
you reach this goal that you've set for
yourself and so you know soon after that
we moved out here and and kind of
changed way we were doing things and
it's it's been great it's been wonderful
but it's that fire that kind of keeps
keeps pushing
um because yeah it's you never know you
know and I've had friends that have
passed away that are younger than me and
stuff and even during Co like we've had
friends pass away from Co that you know
just didn't get had had their whole
chance taken from them and so like you
see that and it's like oh my gosh you
know and then your monster really goes
crazy because it doesn't want to die
either
and you really kind of got to figure out
what's what's the best plan you know to
get what you want and where you want to
be and once you
decalculator ring and see how the
industry works and you're kind like okay
this makes sense this makes sense this
makes sense you see what next the dots
it does make it a little easier
interesting too my mother was diagnosed
with cancer the month after I was born
at 20 and she had Hopkins disease
luckily which is the most curable kind
of cancer but the amount of chemotherapy
she went through in
1981 uh has caused a lot of damage on
her body now later in life so now she's
61 and her heart is completely falling
apart she has a lot of really bad heart
problems and her heart's way too damaged
for a transplant or anything else like
that
too so now you kind of watch that side
as well and you're like okay you're
trying to balance you know everything
else too with that and how much time you
have left with
them and what you can do
to It's kind as a child you know you're
always trying to figure out what you can
do to make your parents proud of you
right um so you kind of always have that
in mind too that it's like okay while
she's still here like what can you do to
be like hey look I just did this thing
that you know maybe they're impressed by
though you know they don't know about
everything so it's sometimes it's hard
to impress like oh I got this thing
happens I don't know what that is like
okay cool but I do remember the first
time my movie came in a store and I
called my dad my dad was always he was
very skeptical of everything and he was
skeptical of like everyone's skeptical
of the film industry when their kids go
into it because they don't understand it
they don't understand how it works they
don't understand there's lots of work
and you can make lots of money and
there's lots of different things about
it um I mean it took my my wife's
parents forever to figure out I mean I
don't you know they've still figured it
out like what exactly we do and and how
we survived but I remember calling my
dad and being like hey the movie came
out today he's like oh okay I was like
no no it's it's a Best Buy you can go
buy it and he's like what are you
talking about I'm like no it's on the
Shelf like go you can go to Best Buy and
pick it up and he called me an hour
later and he's like you're not going to
believe this your movie is a Best Buy
and I'm like I just told you that like
you didn't you didn't believe me I guess
and he was like I just bought every copy
and I'm like well great now nobody else
can watch it because you bought all the
copies uh but it's moments like that
that you know you want you want of
course you want your parents to be proud
of of you and what else did your dad
teach you in his final years I mean I
think the things I learned most from him
in those final years
was that life is not guaranteed you know
tomorrow is not guaranteed and seeing
him get more and more dehabitation and
start once the cancer spread to his
brain and he didn't really understand
like who you were all the time or what
exactly was going on all the time I
think it was really like oh man like you
really need to get your life together
and figure out out how to accomplish
your goals I think in entertainment
people are kind of like oh I want to be
this but they never really think about
how to be that they just assume at some
point someone calls you and you're like
hey I saw this short film you did you're
awesome do you want to direct the next
Avengers movie which of course would be
amazing but it doesn't really work that
way so you got to try to figure out how
to get to the point that you want and
everyone's Point's different I mean some
people want to go and be a makeup artist
on a certain television show or somebody
wants to go and design props for
something else and there's different
ways to do everything there's no there's
no right way to do anything in the
entertainment industry but there are
consistent ways that people have been
become successful so I think it's really
I think one of the things that I've
learned those last few years was to
really laser focus like exactly what I
wanted and then figure out the
combination to be able to get to there
as fast as I could
um he he he and I didn't always see eye
to eye he was definitely a person that
didn't understand a lot um like he
wanted me to play football I can't play
football I can't I'm like the least
athletic person ever um but he played
football so it's like he wanted me to
play football though he wanted to be a
writer and his parents didn't want him
to do that so he had to do what his
parents wanted and luckily he didn't
force that on me but it was just kind of
a a different mentality so you always
kind of have
that besides the creature living in your
back you have this little nagging thing
that always wishes that you had a little
bit more time with him that you could
have done something that he would have
been impressed by and for me my specific
one was he was always obsessed with
France with Paris like he loves France
he he always he went there uh in college
like backpacking like he always wanted
to go back to France and then 3 months
after he died our short got in the cans
Film Festival oh wow and I'm like that
was it that was the moment that's the
one I would have had where he would have
been like wow you actually accomplished
something and you know that was taken
away and I never got to have that moment
and I feel like that will be over my
head until the day I die that one
nagging thing which is really
unfortunate
but you know that's also something
that's driving you to work harder and to
get there quicker and to make it work
because now I have a son and I can
encourage him to do what he wants to do
and he's awesome so he's we're literally
clones of each other like I feel
terrible for my wife she has two of us
now but he is he's amazing and what the
world gives now to kids is incredible
because when I was a kid I didn't have
robotics programs in third grade like we
didn't have all these awesome programs
and and website we have websites or
anything to learn from and he can do
anything he wants like he's he's he
built his own robots at 5 years old and
he's gotten now he's really into
molecular biology which is interesting
he's 11 obsessed with molecular biology
he loves exploring and Science and
everything and it's really exciting to
to go on that Journey with him and
encourage him to do you know whatever he
wants and
hopefully you know he won't have that
moment looming over his head at some
point in life that he didn't think he
had made his father proud and so that's
a that's something else I learned as a
father now to try to work out with my
son so I grew up uh loving the show
Beverly Hills 902 and0 as a kid uh there
was a girl I liked in high
school and uh shocker she it wasn't
reciprocated but she invited me over to
come watch the show when I was like a
junior in high school and I'd never seen
it and there's this character Dylan
McKay he's like the coolest dude and uh
you know all all the all the guys wanted
to to be him and all the girls wanted to
be with him so I after that I was just
like kind of an admirer of the actor
Luke Perry
so fast forward a number of years I'm
back I'm at NASCAR I know I'm going to
leave and we're doing this project This
World War II thing about a racer a race
car owner who served in World War II and
won the Purple Heart so I was like I
think I'll get Luke Perry to narrate
this because I had nothing to lose at
this point and uh he narrates it and I
remember one of the executives saying
like why why is Luke Perry narrating
this I'm like oh his father served in
World War II complete [__] so um he
narrates it went well don't really think
much more it was really cool to work
with him so then about a year later I'm
doing a project for
ESPN and they're looking for a narrator
that kind of had like for Nostalgia
purposes was big in the '90s so I bring
up Luke Perry I'm like I just worked
with this guy earlier this year I sent
them the show they're like he's got a
great voice so now I'm back in front of
him working working with Luke again and
he's like hey I have an idea I'd like to
do a documentary I'm like let's do it
gives me his number now I'm like oh this
is awesome now like working with Luke we
wind up doing a documentary together
about um Mar shot the This Racist uh
baseball owner that was on ESPN and we
just kind of form a friendship you just
meet some people sometimes you just
connect instantaneously he and I just HD
it off hung out every time I was in LA
if he was in town we'd hang out and just
a great dude um he had me over for
Christmas when I was going through a
divorce he invited me over to spend
Christmas because I didn't have my kids
with me and I go over to his house I'm
thinking like it's going to be like a
Walsh family Christmas I'm going to come
in nobody he's there it's just him and
his fiance he's like offering me like
day old chili and I go Luke what's going
on and he's going to Bora Bora the next
day on vacation and I go where is
everybody he goes oh no it's just us and
I said why why did you invite me over if
we're just hanging out and he said well
uh I I remember my first Christmas
without my kids and I didn't want you to
be alone so just a real like hard a goal
person so
he started developing uh the movie Grace
Point with me um before he passed away
and he was going to play one of roles in
it um so sadly he he passed away but
before he did he was like you know he's
like I really like you to meet my friend
uh this girl that I know she grew up in
my hometown our families are friends she
just moved to Charlotte and I was like
all right I was like kind of have a
girlfriend but he's like yeah give me
your number and then he's like okay I'll
have her call you and she never called
you know and I'd bring it up to him and
he' be like I don't know what her deal
is she still didn't call you and I'm
like nope and I'm like he's like I guess
she's just not interested I said I guess
so then he passes
away and I get a message on Instagram
from from this woman Michelle saying hey
Luke talked about you a lot he really
wanted us to meet and I don't really
have anyone to grieve him with in
Charlotte would you want to get lunch so
we went we got lunch and then we wound
up going to his funeral Memorial
together in
LA and uh we've been together ever since
we got married last year so that Luke
kind of brought us together and then my
movie Grace Point is dedicated to Luke
uh at the end it's the last thing on
screen so it was pretty he's somebody
who had a huge impact on my life um
probably as much as anyone in my entire
life he's had an impact and that's crazy
too because you said that you went to
the girl's house that you liked to watch
90210 and it like it's
like kind of came full circle yeah
because it didn't work out with her but
then it's fascinating yeah it didn't
work out when I was 15 but yeah no uh he
he and he you know I think in life and
this this is important for viewers you
should try to gravitate towards people
who celebrate you not just tolerate you
and I think in this
industry sometimes people just are kind
of putting up with you it seems like
sometimes and but you will meet people
that believe in you there's only a few
that you'll meet and it doesn't matter
what Walk of Life they're in but keep
them with keep them close to you when
Luke was making Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood we went out like literally he
was filming that day and we met for
dinner and he was telling me about
Quinton Tarantino you know and I said
what's it like working with Quenton
Tarantino and he said I said what's his
best quality and he I thought Luke was
going to say he's the best writer he's
got the best dialogue and he said he's
the nicest director I've ever worked
with I'm like really and he's like yeah
I go he treats everyone so good on the
set and he would call Luke on his way
home and tell him what a great job he
did and he I could tell he really made
Luke feel great about himself you know
and I was like wow like that is so cool
so at Luke's Mo I went up to Quinton
Tarantino and told him that I told him
that like Luke said the and Tarantino
was like thank you thank you for telling
that really means a lot to me and and he
really appreciated it but Luke said to
me he's like he's like you remind me of
uh Quinton I'm like shut the hell up and
he's like no he said the way your
enthusiasm and whatever and he said to
me he said I'm going to be at your movie
premiere someday
so he wasn't there but I felt like he
was there in
spirit so that was it was um and his
name was on the screen um so he he was
somebody that always made me feel like I
could make the transition from
documentary to scripted like he was
never telling me all the reasons why I
couldn't do it he was just telling me
all the reasons why I could so you know
try to find those people in your life if
you can um that motivate you and Believe
In
You chapter 1 Girl Who Fell from the sky
by Stanley M Brooks and that's the true
story of Julian KY who in
1972 was living in Peru going to the
American school she was 18 uh was in her
senior year her parents were noted
zoologist she had lived part of her
childhood in the Amazon her parents were
cataloging butterflies and bats
and then when she got to middle school
they moved her to Lima and she grew up
there spoke perfect German perfect
English perfect Spanish and uh because
it was uh they're on a different
schedule than us because their seasons
are different than us uh their school
year ends in December so she was both
graduating and going to her prom in
December and uh her dad wanted them to
go to the
Amazon uh on Christmas Eve and she
wanted to stay and so he went early and
she and her mom stayed behind in Lima
and she went to her prom and graduated
with her friends and then they got on a
plane and when the plane was over the
Amazon it was hit by lightning twice and
disintegrated in midair and she was in
the window seat still strapped in and as
she said the I didn't leave the plane
the plane left me and she found herself
uh at 15,000 ft uh in her chair upside
down down pin wheeling and uh she fell
blacked out fell hit the canopy of the
Amazon which broke her fall it's a
miracle but absolutely she's the the
longest free fall without a parachute
and the canopy broke her fall and she uh
landed in the Amazon Woke up had nothing
but a broken collar bone that she knew
of she had one shoe lost her glasses and
for the next nine days followed the
river and the lessons that she learned
from her father and her own desire not
to die and was rescued and uh she's a
friend of mine now she's now in her 50s
and she's an extraordinary woman she
spends half her year in Munich and the
other half in the Amazon trying to save
the rainforest and uh we're going to go
down to bog and uh and and the Amazon
and hopefully tell that story at the
beginning next
year wow chapter two two teachers by
Bill Luke I grew up as a
racist I hated all way
people because of slavery and
segregation saw my father and mother go
through I just hated white I
just and I grew up an angry young black
man and I was tall and awkward and I
didn't talk much and I wrote journals
and
stuff and
um these two people people on their
forget it changed my life Mrs Jean
Walker English teacher very stoic and
like this walking around the class and
she had told me nine times that's right
in my journal when she was teaching and
I just ignored her this basis white
woman and one day
um she says D stay here after
class she said give me that book I said
what the journal give it to me
I'm not giving anything she said if you
don't give me the
journal I'll fail in the class and you
can't
pass through the Jour
ladder pissed off hated her come back to
class in the next several weeks before
spring break and looked at her like if I
could punch in your damn face
man spring break in come back to
class
into the first day I'm going in class
she says Duke come
here she gives me back my
journal and this
book I said what is
this she says the national poetry
contest
book so why do you want what are you giv
this to me for she says look on page
49 she put put two of my poetry poems in
there and it
one I looked at
her this is somebody I
hated she had taken she had read my book
a
journal took the best poems out and
submitted them to a national poetry
contest and I won a
pride I was speechless and she knew I
was speechless she says there's nothing
to
say you're good at what you
do that changed my mind I wasn't quite
sure how to think about race then
because that never happened to
me and then I went to D Community
College
and you know James Hall was the dean he
was in the Navy and stuff and I gotten a
scholarship to Boston University after
Duchess and I went to but you know it
was difficult I got a
scholarship for my classes but I had to
work for room and board and food and
everything I was working seven days a
week exhausted and my grades went that
great and
SE I just gone to the arts
college I decided I was going to come
home to the kipy and I was going to stay
there for a year quit
theu and uh get a job make money so I
can save her for that at
IBM I went during the summer up to visit
my friends at bu and I'm leaving Dr
Hall uh see he says Hey doke come here I
said I I got to go do says Duke come
here come
here J this guy's a boring ass white man
I can't see stand this I go into those
office just to be
curious he says have a
seat I said
okay how you doing Duke I'm okay you're
going to Boston University
right yeah well I'm not I'm I'm I'm
going but I'm quitting I'm staying with
kipy for a year and going to go back
next year he says no you're
not what are you talking about
goes into his vest pocket and hands an
envelope to
me I said what is this he said open
it and the
envelope it was a check of his own
money that paid for three
years of my room and board at W
University
I looked in this man's white man's
face I'm supposed to
ha he doesn't say a
word we look at each
other I just
said thank
you he did not say a
word he put out his hand he said don't
disappoint
me see something happens to your racism
after
that that supposed to be your evil enemy
that's responsible for the negative in
your life and everything the devil the
system the
creature just give me a check to cover
all of my expenses for 3
years how do you hate
that life
changing so I evolved you
know in my Humanity to
understand you cannot put a blanket on
any of everything of
anything it's all about the human being
the person the individual who they
really are behind what their skin color
is behind what their words are their
position it makes no difference to know
the
human if they respect you you respect
them
simple Arab Chinese Japanese Jewish
white black green
Hispanic those topical Services
that's a limited perception
you have the courage to uh engage people
at their level of
humanity you're
living it's easier to dismiss you
because I see you and I make
assumptions I learned a long time
ago
ASU me means it makes a ass out of you
and a ass out of me to assum
and I was taught by those two incidents
it was
incredible it wasn't for those two
people I wouldn't probably be here
day and never asked for
anything all they said is to be your
best that's a
reward it's the
truth chapter three thank God they
professionals by r mean Johnson I was
living um I wasn't doing a show at the
time but I was living on the other side
of town and my dad was sick in the
hospital and my
mother and I actually had my car at that
point and my mother was at the hospital
all day she said well you know what um I
I just don't feel good you know being at
the house by myself can you come over
here and spend the night at the house I
oh of course I hey my own apartment I
said oh yeah so she said well look I've
been at the hospital all day I don't
have no food I haven't cooked maybe you
ought to stop at McDonald's something
and get you something I said oh
okay and I stopped at the McDonald's I
went through the drive-thru it was kind
of late at
night and I ordered my food and the girl
said um well can you uh pull over cuz
you know we'll cook it and bring it out
to you I said okay so I'm sitting in the
car and it's cold I'm running my gas I'm
like oh wait a minute so I said well I'm
going go inside so I came inside and she
looked I said I'm the guy you told to
pull over she said oh okay so they said
we haven't even got it ready yet so so
I'm standing at the
counter and it was like four of us four
guys at the counter you know getting our
food and the little boy in front of me
you know the little McDonald's boy he's
like looking at me and all of a sudden
he looks over like this and he starts
doing this and I'm looking at him like
with the look you got I'm looking at
like what he said and I look
over guy got a s off shotgun pointed
right at my
head and he's telling me raise your
hands
[__] my hands up and these guys
proceeded to rob the
McDonald's and what he did was it was
two one guy came in on the other side
the other door the backup guy
and he uses me as a shield oh and he got
the gun under my arm I like my arms up
he puts the gun under here and he's got
the gun right in the face of that little
boy oh wow and he says empty the
register and the little boy
naturally he said empty the register so
the manager female at this time she's
down here and the guy with the saw off
he says okay empty all the registers she
empties all the registers except mine
and then he saids okay open the safe and
she says well I can't I don't have a
combination it's a Dropbox she said no
you can open the safe she said I can't
open it they come every night and get
the money the security come I get the
money I can't open it he said you lying
he says Get Down On The Ground [__] she
gets down on the
ground on the floor of the other the
place and he leans over the counter and
he [__] the gun and he puts it on the
side of he he says I'mma tell you I'm
going ask you one last time open the
safe so she's like this and she's like a
she starts crying please don't kill me I
can't open the save I got a baby at home
please it's just me and my baby please
please and I'm like like this and I'm
just looking and I'm just like oh my God
and I got the guy behind me with the
little boy like this and I'm like this
and I'm like oh and I'm like this and
all of a sudden the
guy uncocks the
gun and the next thing on my mind is
thank God they
professionals
professionals don't want to shoot
anybody see I found that out from being
in Detroit around the hood
professionals don't want to shoot
anybody they want to get in and get out
so he says okay we're finish getting the
money she jumps up she gets the money
she gets down to my register little boy
this McDonald's money and we said give
him the money give him the money we
yelling and screaming and they say shut
up we didn't shut up give him the money
give him the money it was just
pandemonium so this manager she knocks
him out the way goes in his register and
get the money and put it in one of the
big McD Donald's bags and hand it to the
guy so the first guy out of the place is
the guy that had the pistol under my arm
the last guy out he says anybody trying
anything I'm going come back and kill
everybody he comes down the line of us
they didn't Rob us he comes down the
line of us and takes the the the the gun
across all our backs the smaller my back
I had this gun go down the small of my
back and I'm telling you my life flash
before my eyes when people say oh my
life flash I went from being a baby
[__] in my pants in my diaper all
the way up to it was just like that I'm
like oh and I'm like oh god oh oh oh
like this and he left out when he left
out they took off running I looked they
took off running all of the
customers jumped over the counter and we
was all behind the thing by this time
the cops came in cuz they put they
pushed the silent
alarm and I got to the house and my
mother said oh
she said you didn't get your food I'm
like no I didn't get it so she says uh
what's wrong I said we got stuck up at
McDonald's my mother's like oh okay my
mother got mad at me when I
said I have to
remember what that felt like because one
day I'm going to have to act and have to
recreate that experience my mother got
mad at me that was the end of that story
but that's what happened what you in
that damn acting
and that's when I really finally
realized this is it this is where I'm
supposed to be chapter 4 princes
principles by Alex Munoz I moved to Los
Angeles before I got accepted to film
school and um I just figured if I don't
get into USC or UCLA AFI I'll you know
go assistant director or get a job at a
production company over the studio so I
um the second day I was in LA I got an
internship with a company called called
propaganda films and on my second day of
the job um a cash director says hey
um what's your name and I said Alex she
said oh her name is Lisa fields and she
said um would you like to be a standin
for a famous Rockstar I'm like well who
is it and she said well I can't tell you
I said no I don't want to be a standin
because I want to be behind the camera
so I went back to my boss Steven Price
and I said hey um Lisa Fields wants me
to be a stand for a rock star she won't
tell me who it is and I don't want to do
it and he said why I said because I want
to be a director I don't want to be in
front of the camera I want to be behind
the camera he said you have to do it
you've never been on a professional film
set so I raced back and she was on the
phone ready to hire somebody I said I'll
do it I'll do it she said okay so the
next day I'm on the set
and the DP says okay Alex you can leave
now and I turn around and I'm faced to
to face with Prince and I'm like I
really wasn't a big Prince fan at that
time but I was looking down at him and
our noses were like this far apart I'm
like wow she got four heels on and I'm
taller than you and he just laughed and
he goes can we switch places and I said
sure so um anyway we were told not to
talk to Prince they said do not talk to
him but he would talk to me and on day
six I got my letter of acceptance from
you
USC and um my roommate got the letter
and she said I have something really
important to give you I said okay well
I'm in downtown LA and I'm on this music
video shoot can you bring it so she gave
me the letter I opened it up and I went
into the set and I said I was really
excited I said I got into USC film
school and everyone started clapping and
Prince
said I'm like what he goes come here I'm
like well what did I do so so he said um
so you're going to be a filmmaker I
saides he said let me hear you say that
I said say what he said let me hear you
say you're going to be a filmmaker and I
said I am going to be a filmmaker and he
said I want you to listen closely there
are four roles I want you to consider
abiding by if you are going to pursue
film making in this town I said okay so
he said first one always he pointed up
always remember God the Creator always
remember God and your creator number two
always remember where you come from
because when you forget where you come
from you die as an artist and then
number three
was um break the rules if you follow the
rules you're going to be boring and
you're going to fade
fast and number four
was always give back you must give back
as an
artist and I said okay and he said
repeat repeat what I said and I did I
call these my four purple cornerstones
remember God where you come from um
never forget uh where you come
from I'm sorry let me start over I will
always remember the four I call them my
four purple cornerstones remember God
and the Creator never forget where you
come from Break The Rules and always
always give back and he said Grace is
really important in your journey so
after he tested me on the four you know
core principles he told me he told Rosie
gain's backup singer he said
Rosie pray for this brother that he does
not go down the dark path he needs to
stay on the path of light so Rosie gains
took my hands placed them on Prince's
piano and pray made a prayer of
protection that I wouldn't be seduced by
the dark side you know all the what
Prince called The fleshly Temptations
and she said this is serious we are
praying for you and after she prayed
Prince said amen wow and he said don't
forget what I told you I said I I
won't so
imagine that is a Priceless encounter
that cannot be measured I just moved to
LA I just I finished my undergraduate
work at Santa
Barbara for him to take the time to tell
me these things and share with me his
four core principles and for him to ask
his backup singer Rosie gains to pray
for
me I never forget this
and one of the reasons why when I
decided to move forward with making FY
films a
nonprofit I rumag through my mind I
remember Prince saying always give back
and
he helped
me I don't think I'd be talking about
FYI films If Prince didn't tell me this
about give him back the second part of
the story is so when Prince died right
they did a tribute concert for him and
uh I called the organizes and I said hi
um my name is Alex monos and Prince gave
me some really good advice back in the
day I will do anything I will sweep the
streets I will sell popcorn I will sell
hot dogs I'll be an usher I'll do
security I just want to in my own way
pay tribute to this great artist because
he help he gave me some advice that I'll
never ever forget so they said we'll
call you right back and what happened
was two hours later they called back and
they said we googled you and you're a
filmmaker why don't you do a film
celebrating Prince and I said well the
concert's 10 days away I can't possibly
make a good enough film and I said how
what if I document it so I went to
document this Prince tribute
concert and um the very first interview
I did is is happened to be in the same
exact spot when Prince told me the four
purple cornerstones I was like oh my God
this is where where Prince told me to
remember God remember where you come
from break the Bulls and always get back
and I felt really inspired like my body
was like trembling because I was you
could feel his presence in that area was
the concert was right in front of LA
City Hall which is where they shot the
video how uncanny is that
then um I went out to the audience and
interviewed some people about the
concert and Stevie Wonder does this
amazing rendition of purple rain so I'm
trying to get backstage to interview
Stevie and I can't get to him and the
guards are saying you can't talk to
Stevie he doesn't want to be bothered so
one of my FY film alumni from Hawaii
Adrien Kelly sees me and says hey um
Alex what are you doing here and I said
oh I think I told you when I taught FY
films that when I talk the film Workshop
that my first experience on the film set
was being princess Dana he said yeah
yeah but what are you doing doing here I
said I'm doing a documentary he said
well why do you look mad I said because
Stevie gave the best performance and I
want to interview him and they won't let
me get backstage and he said oh I could
help you and I said Adrien that's really
nice of you but you can't help me he
said Alex I could help you he goes in
the back comes back and he says come on
takes me to Stevie Wonder Stevie
Wonder's nephew oh
wow
so wow I felt like it was full circle so
I mean I got like chicken skin right now
because Prince tells me the importance
of giving back I'm there to do a
documentary about this concert I can't
get to Stevie turns out one of my alumni
never told me he was Stevie Wonder's
nephew gets me backstage because I
believe I had access to Stevie and all
of Princess backup singers and all of
Princess backup
dancers because if I didn't teach that
FYI film Workshop in Hawaii I would have
met Adrien and then two years later I
see Adrien at this concert and he gets
me backstage that's Karma that is oh I'm
doing what I'm supposed to be doing and
I told Adrian I said why didn't you ever
tell me you were Stevie Wonder's nephew
he said I don't know you know Manos I
don't want people my family we don't
want people to like us just because
related to Stevie so we just but but you
earned it because you've come to our
birthday parties and our fourth of July
parties and you never asked any
questions and you showed us love anyway
so okay now you know
so I mean what a what a blessing right
that oh my gosh one of my alumni is
Stevie W's nephew and little did I know
that two and a half years later I would
need him to complete my dog right and
you're in the same spot where you first
met Prince so it was a music video back
in the day in front of LA City Hall yeah
wow chapter five the cat house by Jack
Perez we had a feral cat we we've always
had feral cats come to our house cuz we
have lots of cats and a feral cat a wild
cat
we'll we'll just sense that cat people
live there and a feral cat obviously
cannot be pet or touched or anything
they're they're wild animals but we've
done this over the years and we fed
feral cats so uh you know I guess it's a
little over 10 years ago we were moving
from our apartment and just as we were
about to move a feral cat showed up and
was like feed me and I we were like yes
of course we'll feed you but we're
moving and we were faced suddenly with
this Prospect of like what are we going
to do this this this animal is like
dependent upon us now but we're moving
it got to the point where I was like
literally driving across town every
day to leave food this empty house the
cat was standing there was the saddest
things he's he's like where's my food
I'm like I'm driving across town we I
can't keep this up I can't expect the
new tenants to to take care of him or
whatever so I started looking into
rescues and looking into um that whole
world and it's a you know again I became
educated I was like wow there's just
there's just tons of kill shelters if
you bring an animal to a regular shelter
likely they will be killed certainly a
feral who can never be adopted rarely um
what do you do with a feral cat and so
after a lot of research I found this one
place which i' had never heard of the
cat house on the Kings which was this
one woman's massive property up near
Fresno that she had turned in this ranch
style multi-acre property into this
sanctuary and Adoption Center where she
had you know almost a thousand animals
that were totally cared for it wasn't an
it wasn't a hoarder was like an
operation sure mhm and she was like yeah
you know we actually have a feral you
know section and if you can catch him
you know you can bring him here and I
was like Wow and where everybody else
was like we're full up and they'll kill
him and all this was the one place and
when I when I went up there it was like
one woman and a couple of you maybe one
other person and all of these animals
and I was like this was like the
definition to me of like a saint like
this was like this woman who had
dedicated her whole life to to these
animals literally and was like making it
work she she definitely needed help but
and I I I said to myself my god well
what what can I do in exchange for this
you know you saved this cat's life and
these thousands of other dogs and cats
so I decided to make this YouTube video
I said I'll come back and I'll do a
portrait of you in the place a couple
minutes and you know we'll put it on
YouTube and this is when YouTube was
sort of new you know and and it just we
just as luck would have it there were
enough cat people out there that it
started to go viral and people really
saw that this was a this beautiful soul
that was doing something so unique and
she started to get donations and it
started to get more wellknown and now
you know 10 13 years later it's a it's a
it's considered you know it's a very
well-known institution you know around
the world people come from all over the
world to visit this place and support
support it you know my wife has said you
know it's the most important film you
ever made was that film for the cat
house because you know talking about
direct action that film because it went
viral because I made it because it
exists and it reached people that that
institution that Sanctuary received much
needed donations that saved a lot more
animals and so in terms of doing
something that's valuable truly
valuable that little film you know when
I think about it you know is is you know
definitely up there as being an
important movie of mine just because it
helped It ultimately helped a lot of
animals chapter six station Fire by Andy
rusi do you still have the mini DV tapes
no dust unfortunately you know it's a
bummer I uh about let's see this would
have been 11 years ago uh my house that
was renting uh burned down in one of the
LA at the time the biggest fire in LA
and I lost all of my films I lost all my
writing all my art I used to you know
draw and it was it was it still still
kind of stings but you know truthfully
it was a big um reset button I I it it
it has helped me with uh attachment and
having a lack of it uh it was the year
after my house burned down I just kind
of lived on the road for a year I could
fit everything I owned in a backpack and
so I slept on couches I flew out to
Hawai and slept uh on my buddy's hotel
room while we were working on a movie
out there like it was my life was a bit
of an adventure which I think was good I
think it was it was an interesting life
for a time uh but the at the sacrifice
of losing you know all basically
everything I had created up until 30
years old essentially was this the
station fire yeah the station fire I
remember it yeah yeah it was it was yeah
it was a strange time strange time it's
it's funny to think that that's so long
ago because it does feel so uh relevant
to my life like it really I'm it's it's
altered some of my way of approaching
things and and purchases feel strange to
me still furn
and I like owning things still feels a
little weird a little PTSD I think but
you know I I I my life has been good
since then so
it's I just one of the Stepping Stones I
guess who
knows aside from it you losing all these
things and and and that being the
horrible like negative side and and
losing in a sense your parts of yourself
really went down and that fire do you
think it showed you how temporary things
are and you looked at things in a new
light in in a positive way that way yeah
I would for sure say the silver lining
of losing everything is that you the
idea of impermanence becomes a lot
easier to grasp and I for sure it's the
impermanence of everything Life Health I
mean friendships you know you just never
I think I take some of those things less
for granted now perhaps I hope I don't
know uh and I do wonder you know 20
years from now what will the scars of
that look like will they still be there
will I you know I don't know I moved
into a house a year ago uh after living
in someone else's house for basically 10
years I had like a wing of a house to
myself and uh when I moved into my place
last year I owned nothing I had no bed I
didn't have a chair a desk I had nothing
and so 11 years well 10 years I guess at
the time after the fire was the first
time that I was like okay I got to
purchase some things uh and it felt it
still feels odd I can feel the weight of
those things I liked I liked the idea
that at you know any particular morning
not to say I would do this necessarily
but that I could just kind of pack up
everything into my car and be on my way
and that's everything it's all I need so
yeah I know know it's strange I think
I'm still uh processing all of it you
know in terms of its ultimate lessons no
things do own you it it's true yeah yeah
they have a weight for sure yeah chapter
seven last moments by Adisa 10 years ago
I went to Sione with Isaiah Washington
on a documentary uh film shoot and on
that shoot uh that shoot literally would
change my life uh not only did I get
exposed to SAR leó and and um the
conditions over there because they had
just undergone a Civil War and Isaiah
was looking up his roots and I was part
of the documentary team I had a great
experience but when I came back I had a
near-death experience because I had
cotton a virus over there called the
Hunter virus and when I got back to uh
La um I mean I was just I was just
fatally ill and I had to be rushed to
the hospital I was in the ICU and my
heart stopped beating three times I had
uh multiple organ failure and I was in
really bad shape and the doctors didn't
think I was going to make it nobody
thought I was going to make it so my
mother at that time flew up
here and uh people were just praying I
mean I was just in critical condition
and but
miraculously I made it through yeah I
made it through did they know what it
was they didn't at the time they didn't
and uh it was a good thing that I was at
what they called uh was it Daniel
Freeman Mor hospital and they were like
oh thank God you didn't go to like cedar
cide because the Daniel Freeman Hospital
they could bring in other technicians
from everywhere like they could bring in
people from UCLA they could bring in
doctors from USC to uh to help on my
case right whereas I've been Cedars they
have like clear rules about Cedar Side
doctors working there and you can't
bring others in but because I was at
Daniel Freeman Hospital they were able
to bring another doctor so nobody knew
what I had all I knew was I had multiple
organ failure and my body was shutting
down and this one particular doctor
stayed with me and he had to restart my
heart three times in the middle of the
night and so yeah no was it looked like
I was on my deathbed it looked like I
was on my and actually I thought I was
on my deathbed too the only thing kept
me going was the fact that because at
one point at one point I remember myself
making um sort of this uh resolve that
like you know what I'm gonna if I'm GNA
die my last moments were in Africa my
last moments were playing with children
my last moments were with like you know
um having fun and and sharing of my
gifts with everybody that's where that's
what I was doing after giving out soccer
balls and I had made some serious Rel
some nice relationships over there so I
said you know what if I got to go then
so be it I had made I had made peace
with it you know and uh but it was
another plan for me it was another plan
I'm here and how long were you in the
hospital I was there for about uh I was
probably there for about seven to eight
weeks total but for for like 3 weeks I
was sedated and I was under heavy
sedation as the doctors treated me and
put me on dialysis and we just you know
trying everything to fix me trying
everything to make me better but nothing
worked and they didn't know so they said
they just had to let it run its course
and just let me be uh you know just let
me be sort of get let my body fight it
when I got back and I got in well I
shocked everybody because I told my
mother I want to go back to Africa and
she was like oh no you can't go back to
Africa oh no you're not going to do that
to me again my mother's beside herself
my father uh everybody tripped out I I
mean they were like no you can't go back
because I got an opportunity to go back
with um was it Regina King yeah Regina
King the actress had invited me to go
back and work with her on her
documentary and so they were like no you
can't go back you can't go back
especially going back to serly on the
same place and so B were freaking out
like freaking out and uh but I was
resolved I was like you know what I'm
better I can do this and I wanted to do
this I wanted to be there was some
things that had happened to me by being
sick you know like I was having rations
around my life and what I wanted to do
with my life and and how I wanted to
show up and so yeah and going back to
Africa was part of it I think the light
had turned on more I'm not going to say
it was completely different I mean I was
like I was already like a very positive
optimistic person wanting to do things
but I was probably stopping myself like
the the tournament in Africa and working
with the kids I never thought I could do
that you know like I there was something
about the way I was living life that I
felt like um that was larger than what I
could do right and so I started to so
yes to answer your question once I got
better I started to test the boundaries
more like around greatness and largess
and saying that I can do it I can do
that why not right and so yeah in that
way and then having to experience death
also I mean it just gives you this sense
of I'm not saying immortality but you to
experience and be that close to death
and to know that it can be snapped away
from you that at an instant it it kind
of sharpened my focus about living life
in the present moment to moment and
doing as much as I can in that
moment chapter eight Amy P's journey by
Barbara Seymour girano essentially Amy's
story is that at 19 she contracted
menitis and she died essentially and
then was brought back but she hadd gone
to the hospital she what it does because
it she was so advanced in it that the
the um body tries to save the organs and
the blood rushes from it so uh rushes
from the vital organs and your hands
turn purple her feet turn purple her
cheeks and nose and when it happens it's
like frostbite and so when they got her
to the
hospital um it was touch and go she she
actually did pass away very briefly and
they brought her back um but it was
touch and go for a long long time
and then um in the end they had to uh to
amputate her legs from the ankles down
or the calves down and uh both of
them and but everything else was saved I
mean she did have a lot of other she
lost Hearing in her ear she had all of
these issues so here she was this story
and she'd done a lot already at this
point you know she had been in a Madonna
video and she'd done all these things
but I had to because she'd done so many
things I had to weigh and measure what
was important in the story and that's
where I had to trust my intuition and
where I could actually look at this
guide of the hero's journey because her
life story this particular incident fit
perfectly in it so it isn't a life story
it's not an autobiography it's a moment
in time and a great speech is it doesn't
try to cover too much it's a very narrow
subject and this narrow subject for Amy
was her life this life where she no
longer she had to let go of the old Amy
to embrace the new Amy and we wrote that
in there and every time she goes every
every time I say that line I cry and I
was like good yay but that was the
middle part of the hero's journey the
very point where she then begins to
embrace the journey that she's on so
even though you go over the threshold
right you go through the steps of and I
can't remember all of them but there's
that low point in the circle right and
that's where she began to Rise Like a
Phoenix From the Ashes and she began to
bring back what she learned of course to
cross back over and bring the Elixir
back um to the world which was a speech
so it was really about her experience
and what she learned and the struggles
that she went through and how hard it
was but yet how she wouldn't change
change a thing right and so I had to
figure out do we keep the Madonna video
part in there because my speakers use
slides right the majority I think I've
only worked with a couple who have not
um and high resolution photos I don't
occasionally I let them use text if it's
important to the story but the the
images are wallpaper that really um
helps the emotion stick so the story
will be stickier if the if the
resolutions and the photos of the
resolution the resolution of the photo
photos are are super emotional the
photos themselves and she had a lot of
emotional photos and so
uh we chose the the most important parts
of the story so we had to take them the
audience low to the lowest point to
bring them back up again in the journey
where she was resurrected so she does
the Ted Talk and then what's the
response within what amount of time so
this is so exciting because it's a tedex
talk right so this is 2011 and and she's
like okay I did the talk it's been
posted it took like a month before they
posted it great and this was probably so
we did it in May it probably went up in
June crickets K kitty kitty she got
about 20,000 hits and through December
and then I think it was in
December uh all of a sudden she calls me
like completely worked up oh my God
Barbara what she
go look at the Ted Talk they had taken
the Ted X talk and put it on the Ted
page oh and they don't do that anymore
but they they did it for her and so
that's where you can see it is on the
Ted page they put it on the Ted
page and once that happened it went
viral wow and she's like people are
writing in Arabic like a month later it
just started going everywhere and we
were watching it tick through like you
know 30,000 40,000 50,000 by the hour
and we're like oh my gosh this is so
exciting and yeah so she just captured
the hearts and minds of so many people
her story and it it's it's remarkable
story and she's a remarkable woman just
a really beautiful on the outside but
equally as beautiful on the
inside chapter nine Instinct by wed aami
I work with Madonna and I worked on a
world tour and I befriended um a friend
of mine now a really good friend Jamie
King who is a creative director of the
tour and like so many other artists and
he so just glaze over that real fast so
he would watch me um come in and look at
everything like every I would like
inspect like crazy cuz I knew where I
was I knew that I'm going to learn so
much from this woman and um I left that
job and I left that job and out of the
blue he just texted me one day he's like
hey W how are you let's go get dinner I
want to know what you're up to and so I
went to dinner with him and I drove up
from Anaheim at the Anaheim I think no I
was in whatever Anaheim or Fullerton one
of those two cities in Orange County at
the time and I drove up to LA and I met
him for dinner but what he did not know
is that I was dead broke broke broke
broke okay and this is pretty much right
at the birth of the 2008 Great Recession
so I had quit being a music video
director's assistant I had done some PA
jobs um I was the worst PA you could
ever hire on I mean the amount of effort
I put into not looking
busy it was exhausting and I thought
just do the work you know but like
trying to walk back and forth and like
look busy without really doing the stuff
so Jamie had called me he's like I want
to know what you're up to and um he had
a plan and he had a plan
so we went up and had dinner and another
friend doggo who's a very talented
director joined us also and he asked me
um what are you doing now I'm broke at
this time I have a credit card and I
probably have like $3 $400 in my savings
and that was it because you don't get
paid much as an assistant in Hollywood
you know and so um and I had quit that
to try to do some behind the scenes
video like MTV's making the video and I
got one or two jobs and then it just
stopped stopped but I didn't know that
the recession was born you know and so I
had sto for everyone but people hadn't
been honest about it yet that there
something happened overnight right and
um so I went to dinner with them and
they were asking me like so what are you
doing and I and I would say well I want
to and he's like shut up and I thought
what and I said and I was so confused
because I thought hey you're asking me
what I'm doing or what I want to do and
I'm telling you you're telling me to
shut up and we did this a few times back
and forth and he said don't talk again
until you're actually doing it because
trying is lying and I don't know if he
actually said trying is lying or if I
picked that up somewhere else but uh but
the meaning is the same trying is lying
so you're doing it or you're lying to
yourself but you're not lying to me
right and and he was really rough with
me so he broke me that night and he
rebuilt me that night and he gave me one
of the best lessons I've ever learned in
my life I actually practiced it Without
Really knowing what it was and he gave
me this thing I'm going to tell you
right now and he said no matter what
country you're from No Matter What Faith
you practice or you don't practice um
gender national uh anything doesn't
matter what socioeconomic level one of
the first things that any human being
learns one of the first words is no
because we are told no so many times and
he said it's not the hearing no that's
bad it's why we're telling people no no
I don't want people think you're a bad
baby I don't want people think that I'm
a bad mother I don't want you know be a
good little girl and be quiet right be a
good boy don't show your emotions be
tough and so we are the only living
creatures on this planet that teach our
children to kill their
instincts and so we're sending people
out there to conform and you have to to
a certain extent not to be a freak in
society right but you were sending
people out there and were taking away
their greatest tool that fight or flight
you know and so he said if your
instincts tell you to do something go do
it I don't care if you think you're
going to look like a fool if your
instincts tell you don't get in this car
right now don't get in that car let
everyone think you're crazy but that is
a direct phone call
from you to God or Allah or energy or or
universe or whatever you want to think
is bigger than you okay a greater power
and he said that's a direct phone call
that you're getting at any moment so he
gave me examples he said how many times
have you thought about
somebody and then they text you and
you're like that's so weird I was
thinking about you it's like that's a
connection how many times has a mother
been at work and she's like something is
wrong something is wrong with my baby
and they call the baby s like yeah there
was a small accident you know he or she
is fine that mother knows there's a
connection right and so he
said the the closest you'll ever be to
God or again whatever I don't want
people getting lost on that part of it
or whatever higher power Mother
Nature um is when you listen to your
instincts and he's like if you want to
photograph everybody in all green paint
go do it something is telling you this
is going to be good for your career now
that night so that's what I mean by he
broke me and then he rebuilt me and he
was setting in an infrastructure that I
had already been using and how I I've
acted a lot in my earlier career and my
school and everything sorry that's okay
and so he had set like the the structure
the infrastructure of like things that I
a guideline and I had been doing it but
I didn't know this was my instincts okay
and um I went home thank God he paid for
dinner cuz I did not have money to even
pay for my portions and we had like
drinks and dessert and appetizer I'm
like oh my God you know this is
expensive and he sent me on my way and
for like a week after I had um this
weird feeling apparently was my
instincts but this weird foreign feeling
that I should buy a
camera but I didn't like when I tell you
I did not even know that a a camera you
can detach a lens from a camera like a
DSLR I guess mirrorless now whatever I
did not even know you could do that I
didn't know what an ISO was I knew
nothing nothing about a camera and so
but I had this feeling go buy a camera
jobs are not coming in rent is coming up
and I only have a few hundred bucks on a
credit card left and I sat on it and I
pushed it down and it just kept
persisting kept persisting for I want to
say a week week and a half or something
like that this feeling was there and it
would not go away and I don't know what
made
me but I decided to listen to my
instincts and I went into a camera shop
and um and I I'm such so naive but I
went in and I said H um I said hi um I
have
$2,000 on my credit card and I said I
have $2,000 and I want to be a
photographer and he sold me like
$1,998 and whatever nothing else left in
the store to buy not even doublea
batteries cuz it's was like it was I
mean they maxed out my
card and I bought a a 40D which was not
even a real it was like a pro suumer
camera and it was a good camera but I'm
just saying it wasn't like it was
whatever it was like a rebel today or
something and I had no I sat in my car
and I remember the most nauseous feeling
and I thought what did I do I even and
now I can't even get a cash advance on
my last credit card because I maxed that
sucker out I went home and just I was
just I was a
mess and what a dramatic person but I
was a mess you know and I thought
man I don't even know how to turn this
thing on like no joke I have no idea how
to turn this thing I did not know what a
single I didn't know a single thing okay
but about I started shooting things like
um leaves on a tree and a trail of ants
and it was all horrible pictures I got a
call because I wanted to do behind the
scenes video and I got a call because of
a friend of a friend of a friend and
they were like hi is wallet there I'm
like right and I was like yes what are
you selling me stranger exactly and they
said hey somebody said you have a video
camera and at the time it was like the
uh mini DV tape so there they were like
hey you I heard you have a um an HD
camera and because everyone was using
the pan Sonic dvx 100 which was like not
fully HD I think um whatever
but I said yes and I was so excited
because I can buy food now okay and put
food in the fridge and they said Usher
needs somebody to come to the Kodak
Theater right now and I'm packing
everything in a bag throwing everything
didn't even have camera bags like I put
them in a gym bag and stuff and I'm
about to close the door and that weird
feeling in my gut said Usher doesn't
know why you're hired it say
manager go get that stupid camera you
just bought to the still camera and I
grabbed it and I ran on the car and I
remember I had a little Blackberry Curve
with the ball and I wrote F stop means
this ISO means this and you know
aperture means this whatever and
um and that was pretty much our shutter
speed and and and I I went there I went
underground like two three levels I said
hi to usher and I'm one of those people
that when I'm nervous I look like I look
like I'm hiding a bomb I'm telling you
it's like this it just looks so bad you
know and um I don't have a poker face
whatsoever and I was just shooting stuff
and I decided to put the video camera on
a tripod in the corner so now looks like
a security camera but us sure has a
footage and I wish I I had it but um of
me trying to figure this out and looking
at my Blackberry I'm like okay this
button did this and I'll take pictures
and I didn't even know that um I had a
one gigabyte card CF card so my compact
flash was one and I was shooting on jpeg
small did not even know about these
settings that they existed or that raw
was such a thing okay and I'm shooting
and I'm shooting machine gun style
because I'm banking on quantity here not
quality and pictures are like cuz they
had the the neon tubes pictures are
coming out like all different colors but
it is not the color you want to see and
Usher's coming out blurry um because I'm
apparently on like like not even at 40 I
think it was like it was basically it
was I pretty much almost had the bul
button you know the like it was just
dragging the shutter everything was
blurry and I'm r up the iso as high as
possible I'm just hitting any button
okay and aser looks at me and says what
F stop are you
using and yo when I tell you I have
mastered how to die on the inside and
keep a calm
face I think I'm keep it a calm face I
that gut feeling said walk away yeah I
was on autopilot I don't think that was
valid that day okay I was on autopilot
that gut feeling said walk away and I
remember it was instant and said it's
better that he thinks you're a crazy
artist than someone who has no idea
which was the truth okay and um actually
now I think both are true but but um I
went
upstairs I looked up again because I
wrote FST but I had to look up I'm like
what did this mean you know with all
these performers street performers on
and I'm like come on Verizon you know
like give me the reception everything
and I went back down in case he asked me
and I wrote it down because I'd be like
f-stop is this I'm like I am using 5.6
you know but he didn't ask me again and
I just kept shooting I went home I went
home and um sewed down and I looked at
all the pictures and I did not even know
that photoshop exist I did not know
Photoshop was a thing the whole
Institute of
adobe was not even in my in my Spectrum
whatsoever okay so I decided to download
all the pictures open them up
individually inside the preview like
what you would open up a PDF in and so
you have the option of bringing down
contrast exposure
saturation Hue and that's about it and
I'm looking at these pictures I'm like I
don't know where Usher is because
everything is blurry I can't tell you
know anything and out of that I probably
pulled under 10 images that you can
identify it was Usher and that he was
actually in focus on accident okay and I
pulled up about 10 of them and this is
me opening a a picture one at a time I'm
like no next it was a disaster okay and
then I it was like I did not even know
such a thing of Lightroom existed so I
would take him in one folder copy him
paste him into a second folder as I'm as
I'm eliminating which pictures I want
you know and narrowing down and I found
about 10 12 maybe nine I don't know but
I I opened them up in that preview panel
and I thought oh my God they're every
color under the
rainbow and I remember again that that
instinct was really and play and was
like just turned it all black and white
and I turned them I desaturated all of
them and I boosted the contrast a little
bit they're already blurry sometimes and
they were already high high high ISO so
super grainy and I sent them to Benny
Medina who was Asher's manager at the
time now he does JLo and I think J JLo
only and um they called me within like
30 minutes and they said
W I don't know how you guessed it but we
sent the pictures to Usher and his whole
new thing for the new album is old
Hollywood and he wants these black and
white grainy imperfect images and so we
want to know would you be willing to
work with with him and be his personal
photographer oh my gosh and that like
that to me is like that's the perfect
story in my career of following your
instincts and just having faith in
it I mean I know that people are
listening to this and they're like he's
crazy like how am I going to take that
chance but that was me just following
instincts from the start and going
there's a there's this weird feeling and
I don't know what's going on I'm going
to follow it and every single day I
would learn one new thing on YouTube and
I would type things like what does
exposure mean and I would study it
because a history major you know ask me
about Civil War I'll tell you everything
about it you know but and I was um and I
would learn that one thing and then I
was not allowed to go to bed until I
learned one new thing every single day
so after a week it was no big deal after
a month it was no big deal by the end of
the second month I started started
adding up the things that I knew you
know and so Usher would say hey let's
shoot over over there I'm like no let's
not cuz I hadn't even reached that yet I
was just on natural window light you
know and I was like no that's not let's
just stand over here and do it and I
would just so whatever I learned the
night before I would practice it on him
the next day and he's like you have such
a vast style like you do so many things
I'm like dud you don't even know like
I'm on YouTube every night like learning
things and then coming downstairs and
practicing it on you and I learned how
to photograph on tour with
Usher